and now a moment of silence please
well they ain't getting any better
[Music]
hey folks so it's time for us to talk
about an lgbtq plus representation topic
and yeah i'm skipping the whole taking
off the hat letting the hair down thing
we're just gonna
start this way this time because i
figured that by this point if people
have not
already caught on to the fact that i am
gender fluid
and you know this is how i look
sometimes and that's why i have a dog in
this race
uh when it comes to representation and
things like that i
i don't know what to say to those people
anymore so uh we're just gonna kick it
off
uh right like this before we get into it
though
this particular episode of council of
geeks is sponsored by radio
vs the martians it's a podcast series
that features mike gillis and casey
doran as they run down
basically whatever geeky stuff they feel
like talking about that given
conversation and they have all kinds of
guests they talk about
star wars and game of thrones and comic
books and batman and wrestling and
arnold schwarzenegger seriously they're
watching every arnold schwarzenegger
movie it's kind of amazing
so that's radio versus the martians
radio versus the martians.com or
wherever you get your podcast
thanks guys
let's talk about the trope commonly
referred to as
barrier gays or bury your queers because
i think it applies to more than that
i've actually got quite a bit to cover
here so let's start by explaining what
this trope
even is and what the term means because
it's important that everybody's
operating on the same base level of
knowledge here
in the simplest terms it refers to the
tendency of lgbtq plus characters in
entertainment especially
mainstream entertainment to end up dead
by the time the story that they appear
in is concluded
this is the kind of thing i've actually
wanted to talk about for a while because
it gets into the actual substance of
representation rather than
you know getting hung up on things like
whether or not
representation needs to be there at all
or
why the creators chose to have it or
things like that i've talked about that
stuff a lot but that's all like the
preemptive
now let's actually talk about when it
happens and to be really blunt about it
if you're some form of lgbtq plus and a
significant percentage if not the
majority of characters in tv
and movies that are also part of that
community
end up dying that doesn't leave you with
the best
feeling in the world but we'll come back
to that
let's start with why this trope even
exists in the first place
its prevalence came about largely as a
loophole
that was exploited to be able to even
use these kinds of characters to tell
these kinds of stories at all because
there is and always has been a market
for
what is considered to be cd or
scandalous tales which for a very long
time any kind of queer content
would be considered to be that just by
its very nature so for a long time
publishers because we are talking like
back at the printed word here
would not want to risk the ire of either
governing officials or moral crusaders
by appearing to advocate
for deviancy so they would basically
just split the difference
by not glamorizing the lifestyle and
having
the gay people end up dead and that
pretty much
solved the problem as long as the
story's ultimate message in regard to
being anything other than
straight and cisgender was it gets you
killed or leaves you broken
well it was more likely to be allowed
through the gates
and out into the world to actually be
consumed as entertainment
a parallel comparison would be uh the
haze code
and how that treated depiction of
criminals and drug use uh the haze code
if you didn't already know that was a
set of restrictions that hollywood
actually imposed on itself
um about what could or couldn't be
depicted
in movies it was in effect from 1930
to 1968 at most major studios and one of
its caveats
was that criminal behavior was not to be
depicted as sympathetic or glamorous now
you still got movies where the main
character was
a gangster but the gangster had to be
dead by the end of the movie
i mean that was pretty much james
cagney's entire career as a lead actor
and while the haze code specifically
forbade any overt depiction of what is
considered sexual deviancy their words
which
led to the standardization of gay coding
in film but that's
kind of a topic for another day most
media around the same time basically
appeared to adopt that general model
that the haze code had for crime
and used that approach when portraying
lgbtq plus
characters so this made all k
all gay characters die the standard
operating procedure for
a very long time and is one of the
reasons why
patricia highsmith's novel the price of
salt which you may
know better by its movie adaptation in
2015
carol it's why that story was so
groundbreaking because prior to its 1952
publication
lesbian romance was a pretty well
established subgenre of pulp fiction
but they always ended in tragedy
and to say that the price of salt has a
happy ending might be stretching it
slightly but
it at least has a hopeful one and
everyone's still
alive and well how groundbreaking was
this
well keep in mind that by this point
highsmith already had a successful book
turned into a hitchcock movie with
strangers on a train
but she wouldn't put her name on the
price of salt and actually didn't
acknowledge authorship
until 38 years
later when it was finally reprinted with
her name on it in 1990
highsmith herself summed up all of this
best
in the afterword of the book she stated
that prior to this book
homosexual male and females in american
novels
had to pay for their deviation
by cutting their wrists drowning
themselves in a swimming pool
or by switching to heterosexuality so it
was stated
or by collapsing alone
miserable and shunned into a depression
equal to hell
so okay now we know why the trope was
established and a bit about the period
where it
was leaned on the most heavily
why is it stuck around into current
entertainment
well a big part is just
it just has to do with how formative the
years of fiction and entertainment
were during the period when
that was just kind of the way things
were
i mean the price of salt may have broken
the taboo in 52
and the haze code may have gone away in
68 but
before and even after that
there were decades of storytelling that
locked in
what was normal or expected when it came
to depictions of
all kinds of characters and that
included gay people
and those formulas those tropes they're
really hard to shake off
once they're embedded especially if
you're not actually consciously aware of
them which
i would say many creators aren't even
today
i should actually zero in on the
question of whether i'm
addressing an outdated problem or does
this
actually still go on oh yeah
it it definitely does though it gets
called out way more than it used to
like for example even if you haven't
watched netflix's voltron series which
actually i haven't either you may still
have caught wind of the anger that was
centered around the introduction and
then
killing off after extremely brief
appearances of
a gay character named adam in a later
season
there was also an element of queer
baiting in there since adam had actually
been teased on promotional material like
he was some kind of major character
and was really little more than a
glorified extra
which actually feeds into my next point
because
while bury your gaze barrier queers
whichever
in regards to main characters i would
actually say it doesn't happen as often
as it used to
it's still pretty prevalent when it
comes to
supporting characters but i don't
believe that to actually be by design
just rather by carelessness
by that what i mean is in most stories
there's
an assemblage of supporting characters
whose backstory is
really never going to get delved into
and they're never really going to be
driving the plot
it's therefore easy to just stamp
these kinds of characters with any
number of cast diversifying traits
and despite some cries of agenda
this is most often done for a very
practical purpose
of just making characters more distinct
from each other and easier to tell apart
especially in something like animation
so you've written a story you know your
main characters through and through but
you know there's 20 to 50 background and
supporting characters
who have plot function but they don't
require a
ton of depth or detail
i mean they're blank slates and they
could really be anything
so you go ahead and apply some easily
established distinctions to help make
them seem
less generic make the world feel more
fleshed out
you make this one black that one's asian
that one's gay uh that one's overweight
oh this one's a god hey
we'll have that one be in a wheelchair
now you can call this tokenism but it is
still just kind of
what tends to happen and i don't mean to
paint this approach as automatically
being a bad thing in fact
it can help normalize the existence of
marginalized or underrepresented groups
to
have them be just spread about and
just exist you know almost like they're
normal people
but it often means that not much care is
given to the implications of
making these kinds of characters
whatever it is you end up making them
it's the same root cause of the black
characters in horror movies always die
trope it's not that horror movie
directors or writers
hate black people it's that the
diversity generally gets spread among
the
supporting cast and the supporting cast
and horror movie is
inherently more disposable and usually
just there to be killed
so when lgbtq plus characters are
dispersed among the supporting
characters and that cast
it means that it's getting applied to
what are frankly the most
disposable and the most likely to be
casually removed
in order to up the stakes or establish a
danger or impact one of the main
characters
by their dying
so now it's time to come back to how
this kind of thing can leave the lgbtq
plus audience actually feeling
the frequency of this kind of thing
which again
mostly happens by careless coincidence
rather than by design
it reinforces this general idea that we
are inherently less important and more
disposable
honestly i find barrier gays easier to
defend
when it's a lead character because
there's usually some degree of thought
and consideration going on there you
know some degree of
depth that gives context for why the
trope
is being used i find the death of a
gay character in something like
brokeback mountain
way easier to swallow than say
the casual smearing of a gay character
across the highway
in bride of chucky boy
but those films have never been directly
compared before
but my point is that with supporting
characters where
this whole thing is more prevalent it
just kind of happens
dead queer whoopsy daisy oh well moving
on
and many lgbtq plus audiences already
have a pretty high degree of anxiety
about our place in society so getting
this vibe off of entertainment doesn't
really do much to assuage that
i can actually do a nice little compare
and contrast within the same source for
two comparison case studies let's start
with buffy the vampire slayer the first
confirmed homosexual character on the
show is that of
larry introduced in the second season he
gets killed in the finale of season
three
with really no ceremony
actually it's so fast that it honestly
didn't register with me that
the hit he took would have killed him
until it got
confirmed outright in the sixth season
killed so casually that you could easily
miss
the fact that he even died now contrast
that with the death of
tara in that same sixth season that i
mentioned
while still safely labeled a supporting
character tara was at that point part of
the main
cast actress in the opening credits
everything
and the show appropriately treated her
death
with the weight and the gravity
one would want out of a character this
important
to both the other characters on the show
and the fans
now it still is a bit of bury your gaze
but i point this out to illustrate how
the
casual instances that are generally
you know the supporting character ones
tend to be the bigger problem
another contrast actually exists in
doctor who between
a litany of casually killed characters
and the
death quote unquote of series 10
companion bill
bill's death again is treated as a
tragedy
as something with weight and meaning and
also thankfully doesn't happen
because she's gay so that helps
less helpful though is that both before
and after
bill we have fodder deaths of characters
offhandedly established as gay in
episodes like
unicorn on the wasp midnight a good man
goes to war arachnids in the uk
even the latest episode that aired as of
this taping resolution
heck look bill's inclusion under barrier
gays might even be questionable because
she was kind of
saved and she was saved by what remains
of a character who very clearly
was a victim of barrier gays who had
died in the very first episode of that
season
does one well done highlighted character
counterbalance the many
dead fodder gay characters the show has
produced
i mean that's a call for any given
viewer to make for themselves but
sometimes it does feel like the show is
counting on that
balancing out since it hasn't stopped
since bill came and went
so not all of these instances are as
egregious as
others you can refer back to my video on
uh problematic patterns as to why
the ubiquity of the trope is still a
problem
regardless of the merits of some
individual instances of
its use and to be clear because i know
somebody's gonna claim otherwise i'm not
saying this means that you can never
kill off a gay character
but the reason something is a trope
isn't
just that it's frequently used is that
it's overused
it's expected it's what
pretty much always happens and another
word for that is a cliche
so a writer or director or creator of
any kind
should be approaching killing off an
lgbtq plus character
the same way one should approach
anything that is overdone
approach it the same way you would say
damsel in distress because it's such a
standard expectation
that if you're going to use it there
have better be some
thought behind how it actually plays out
otherwise we've seen it before
because just using the trope straight is
boring
it's expected and it's lazy
so of course gay characters can die but
since that's such a cliche maybe think
about
why you're doing it and if you can't
come up with a good reason
then maybe think about doing something
else
if only to not be so dang predictable
so that's my thoughts on barrier gays
barrier queers bury your
non-hetero non-cisgender folks
so what are your thoughts on this trope
what
do you think is the most egregious
example you have seen of it or any other
thought shots yes let's share some shots
now
share your thoughts with me down in the
comments let's talk about it
if you like what i did i hope that you
will hit the like button that is a big
help
also consider subscribing and if you
really want to help out
i also have a patreon where you can
support me and help
make this better so
links for all that is down below you
know how the buttons work you don't need
me to tell you so click on stuff have a
good time
or don't you don't have to because
at the end of the day folks you're the
council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you